and before we give an update on the
latest figures on the corona virus and
also our work to help support the
vulnerable get access to food today is
of course the 75th anniversary of VE Day
and although many of the lockdown
measures that are in place and the
social distancing measures are in place
mean that many of the planned events
have been unable to take place as
originally envisaged today is an
important day to pause and remember and
seventy-five years ago people poured
into the streets of our Scout cities to
celebrate the end of that most difficult
conflict our soldiers fought around the
world there were countless acts of
bravery 450 fifty thousand British
people sadly lost their lives and it was
a moment when our whole country pulled
together as Defra secretary I would like
to take this opportunity to record the
efforts of those who also contributed in
a non-military way in particular our
farmers who stepped up to ensure that
the nation was fed and the many women
who responded to the call to join the
women's Land Army in a moment I am going
to give you an update on our work to
support the vulnerable get access to
food but firstly let me give you an
update on the latest data from the Kobra
coronavirus data file I can report the
through the government's ongoing
monitoring and testing program as of
today 1 million 631 thousand 561 tests
for corona virus have now been carried
out in the UK including 97 thousand and
29,000 the 29 tests carried out
yesterday
two hundred and eleven thousand three
hundred and sixty-four people have
tested positive and that's an increase
of four thousand six hundred and forty
nine cases since yesterday 11788 people
are currently in hospital with the
corona virus down from 12 thousand six
hundred and eighty eight the previous
day and sadly of those tested positive
for corona virus
across all settings 30 1241 have now
died that's an increase of 626
fatalities since yesterday
this new figure includes deaths in all
settings not just in hospitals and we
express our deepest condolences to the
families and friends of these victims
turning now to our work to help the
vulnerable get access to food firstly
for the so called shielded cohort that's
those who are clinically vulnerable over
a million food parcels have now been
delivered to these households and in
addition all of those on the shielded
cohort have been added to a list giving
them priority access to supermarket
delivery slots so far around 400,000
people have been offered priority
delivery slots by supermarkets and
around 1 million orders have been placed
ensuring that people can shop normally
and purchase the goods that they want to
buy there is of course a wider
vulnerable group those perhaps you have
disabilities who are elderly and perhaps
don't have neighbors or relatives close
by to help them or indeed those with
other conditions that don't put them in
the clinically shielded group but
nevertheless make them vulnerable and
we've been working with local
authorities and some of the leading
charities such as Age UK to put together
a package of support to help these
people get access to food and many local
authorities and charities have also been
accessing the Good Samaritan app as part
of the NHS responder volunteer program
and so far 79 thousand shopping runs
have been carried out by volunteers
engaged in that program in addition we
are continuing to work with supermarkets
to make available additional priority
slots for those in this group but we
also recognize that the economic impacts
of Corona
virus means that vulnerability is not
just about physical access to food for
some there is also financial
vulnerability so today we are announcing
a new 16 million pound fund to support
frontline food charities the fund will
be used by fair share and Rapp to
continue and support and increase the
food redistribution work that they
already do and will significantly expand
their sourcing capacity they will be
delivering food to around 5,000
frontline Charities and these include
refuges homeless shelters and
rehabilitation centers finally
unconcious that there is a great deal of
speculation about what the Prime
Minister might say on Sunday when he
outlines a roadmap for the future and
how we will evolve the current
restrictions the Prime Minister will
outline any changes to the guidance on
Sunday but in the meantime in spite of
the sunny bank holiday it is vitally
important that we continue to abide by
the current restrictions stay at home to
protect the NHS and save lives thank you